the world is changing technology is
absolutely vital to fast forward these
changes
I'm Sam bird and I drive an electric
racing car
comedy is a single seater racing
championship but purely for electric
vehicles formulary is gonna be the
catalyst for people believing that
electric vehicles are cool fun and that
they are the future there's no other
place in the world where you can push
these technologies so hard that you can
be merciful
formulary is really in the here in the
now
electric cars there are computers on
wheels not only we have to develop the
hardware of the car or show the murderer
the inverter but also we have an awful
lot of software to be developing they
are probably a hundred different topics
that we can work on to improve the
overall efficiency of our electric
racing cars that's why our partnership
with Hewlett Packard Enterprise is so
important utopic identify the design the
really bespoke IT solution it is able to
condense the amount of time it takes on
the data to go from the car to the
engineers we have reduced that time from
about two minutes to 10 seconds that
might sound a marginal but shaving two
minutes of non-productive time is
absolutely critical
Racing is important not only from a
sporting perspective but from a life
perspective I firmly believe that for
Murray series will make more people on
the planet go green because the
technology from here or go into the
production line and make a better more
affordable electric car it's not so much
about the speed of the car themselves
it's about the speed of how our team
operates and how quickly were able to
adopt new technologies and integrate
them into our race cars
that's why formula is so important this
is the catalyst of change
[Music]